- And we saw the CDC
officials and NIH
and Fauci specifically
attack me along with
Elizabeth Warren and Rachel
Maddow, night after night.
But we also, you know,
recognized too that people
in my state weren't
necessarily supportive either.
You know, there was times
where it was hard to find
a lot of encouragement, even
from people who lived here,
that my Lieutenant
Governor tells the story
that he would get phone calls
from even our best supporters
that would say, hey, you gotta
get the governor in line.
(relaxing music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
joining me today is the
Governor of the great
state of South Dakota,
as well as author
of the new book,
Not My First Rodeo:
Lessons from the Heartland.
Governor Kristi Noem.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Oh, thank you. I'm
thrilled to be here.
I appreciate the invitation.
- I am glad to
finally chat with you.
Because I always tell
people I have a short list.
It's a very short list.
I have it in front of me
right now of sane politicians
and you're on the list,
so congratulations.
- Oh, good.
Oh, it's a good day.
That's wonderful to hear.
I'll put it on my resume.
- There you go.
So I want to dive into
a bit about the book
and a bit about hot topics
of the day and a bunch more.
But in the book you kind
of go into your history,
your childhood, and really
how it sets up a lot
of your political beliefs.
So I thought we could
just start there
maybe for some of the people
that don't know too
much about your bio.
- Well, I think a lot of
people would look at me
writing a book and think
it's a book about politics
and it's really not.
It's about my life lived so far.
Most people heard my name for
the first time during COVID
and didn't know
anything about me.
Maybe made some
assumptions based on
the decisions that I was making.
And I think it's
important that for people
to understand the
decisions that I make,
they have to know a
little bit about me.
The way I grew up, I
think was pretty special.
There's a lot of life lessons
I learned from my family,
my faith and the ranch.
And I think it is
some of those lessons,
that helped South Dakota and
myself do what we've done
the last couple of years.
That I believe really
is an inspiration
to the rest of the country.
Here in South Dakota we
have embraced freedom,
unlike any other state.
And it really is
benefiting not only
the people who live here,
but also our economy
and our way of life.
- Yeah, it really has.
I mentioned to you right
before we started that,
although I didn't
quite get to meet you.
We were separated
by about five feet.
We walked past each
other at Freedom Fest
after you had spoke.
And then I went to Mount
Rushmore that very day.
It was the first time
I had ever been there
and just the spirit of America.
And it was still the
middle of COVID I suppose,
but just the amount
of people that were
out in street festivals, out
and about happy, you know,
some wearing masks, some not.
Making decisions for themselves.
It was so refreshing.
But can you go into
a little bit of that,
growing up in the Heartland,
and what some of that family
stuff that you learned,
maybe how that translated
into some of the politics
that we'll get to?
- Well, my dad was a
cowboy and he was tough.
All we did was work and if we
didn't work, we were hunting.
In fact, even our
family vacations
were loading the horses
up in the trailer
and headed to the
mountains for two weeks,
on elk hunts or big game hunts.
And so it was a very
different childhood maybe,
than typically
what American kids
get the chance to
experience today.
But I also learned a
lot from having a dad
that gave us incredibly
hard things to do.
You know, many times growing up,
I thought is this guy
trying to kill us?
Cause he just gave
us challenges.
But I realized
that by doing that,
he made us into problem solvers.
And when we did something
that was very hard
that we didn't think
we could accomplish,
it gave us confidence to
tackle the next biggest thing.
So, a lot of the
stories in the book
are working with
cattle or hunting trips
or lessons learned
from my mom and dad.
But they also address
kind of a way of life,
that's kind of about
the American West,
that I think people are still
very curious about today.
And our politics were not
talked about in our home.
We weren't a political
family at all.
Instead they were
lived, they were in
how we lived our way of life.
In fact, I remember I was
telling somebody the other day,
when South Dakota passed the
law that required seat belts.
I remember being young and
watching my dad take a jackknife
and then cut the seat belts
out of his brand new pickup.
And I asked him why
he was doing that.
And he told me because the
state had just passed a law
that mandated it and it
wasn't that he was against
wearing his seatbelt,
he wore his seatbelt.
It was that he was
against the government
telling him he had to.
And it was lessons like that.
That really made me
think about government,
its role in your life
in a very different way,
than I think a lot of people
get the chance to today,
when they just turn on the news
and get their opinions that way.
- So from a family that wasn't
necessarily talking politics,
but sort of living
it as you describe.
What possessed you to
get into this crazy game
known as politics of today.
- You know, I would
say it was a tragedy.
We'd lost my dad in an
accident on our farm,
when he was 49 years old,
I was 22 at the time.
I was married, I'd gotten
married when I was 20.
But I was still going to college
and it just turned our
whole lives upside down.
He was kind of Superman.
You know, we had a very
large farming operation
and ranching operation,
probably one of the
largest in the state.
Many other businesses.
And when he was
gone, we had no idea
how we were gonna keep
the operation going.
In fact, I became the
general manager at 22
and you know, had a lot
of people working for us,
relying on us, trying not
to lose our family business.
When I got a letter in
the mail from the IRS
that said we owed death taxes
and I hadn't heard of
death taxes before that.
But all of a sudden,
because we had this tragedy
and our whole lives have
been turned upside down.
Now we owed hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars
to the federal government in
taxes and it made me angry.
So that's what got me involved.
Is I just started
showing up at meetings.
I was passionate
about tax reform.
At that time our Senator from
South Dakota was Tom Daschle.
He was the US Senate
Majority Leader at the time.
And I showed up at
all of his meetings
and started talking policy
and remembering that my dad
always told us growing up,
Kristi, we don't complain
about things, we fix 'em.
But it took me 10 years
to pay off those taxes.
So during that time I
was pretty passionate
about getting rid
of that unfair tax
that hits a family
at a time of tragedy.
- Yeah. So as you
mentioned earlier,
what sort of put you
on the map nationally
was the COVID situation and
that you didn't go for lockdowns
and you fought the
system and all of that.
As you may know, I lived in
California for most of COVID.
I now live in the
free state of Florida.
And as I keep
telling my audience,
it's like living
in another country,
I genuinely feel that
I left one country
and moved to another, which
is the beauty of federalism.
Can you talk a little bit
about those first couple weeks
of COVID, the pressure
you were under,
and how you made your
decisions, you know,
who you were taking
advice from, et cetera?
- Well, I would say it was,
it was immense pressure.
You know, we were
told right away
before the virus even came
to the state of South Dakota
that I would have over
300,000 people die,
from this virus that was coming
and that I needed to
do something about it.
To slow down the spread
and protect people
who were vulnerable.
So I think I did what
every other governor did,
talked to a lot of health
officials and experts.
Studied the virus,
learned from other states
when they were first affected.
What I did differently
was, I believe,
I spent a lot more time
with my general counsel,
a lot of time with
constitutional attorneys.
I really wanted to understand
what my job was as governor
and what my job wasn't, what
authority I did not have,
cause I just believe
that when leaders
overstep their authority,
especially in a time
of crisis like that,
that that's really when we break
the foundation of this country.
I knew for a fact,
I did not want to be the
governor who did that.
So South Dakota did end
up being the only state
that never once
closed a business
or mandated anything while other
states were closing beaches
and closing businesses
and stopping big
meetings and gatherings.
South Dakota did
something very different.
In fact, I was shocked and
surprised how people were
rolling over and giving up
their freedoms, in many states.
So we went on the
offense, you know,
we ran a national advertising
campaign right away in 2020,
inviting everybody to come
to South Dakota while,
while your state's locked down,
come and spend
time here be free.
And hundreds of
thousands of people came,
they came and spent
some time here.
And then many of those
people went back home,
packed up their
families and moved here.
So it's been an
incredible testimony,
to what happened
in that pandemic.
- I think the very day,
that crazy video of
the cop chasing down the
guy in Malibu on the beach,
remember that viral video.
- Yes I do.
Absolutely.
I remember that day and I
lived not too far from there.
I saw you on Fox
saying you know,
we're gonna stay open
and really thinking, man,
this is what's happening
in America right now.
It's just many, many
different countries.
So were you talking to
other governors also?
I mean, you know, some
like DeSantis obviously
were doing something a lot
closer to what you were doing,
but you know, Gavin Newsom
who was my governor in Cali
was obviously doing
something very different.
Hochul up in or at the time
it was Cuomo in New York,
but now Hochul has continued
a lot of that stuff.
- Well, we talked a lot.
Not so much with
Democrat governors.
You know, there would be
different conference calls
through the National
Governor's Association
that were hosted
and facilitated.
But I learned quickly that
those weren't beneficial,
that we weren't getting any
new information from them.
And that we needed to prioritize
where my time was being spent.
We did have conference
calls with governors
who were keeping
their states open.
And you know, we just
organized that ourselves.
We were all Republicans,
but we had weekly,
sometimes biweekly phone
calls with learning
what we could learn about
the virus from each other.
It was a governor's only call.
Also learning what
other people were doing,
what measures they were taking,
what they were recommending.
But we also made sure
that that call only stayed
for the governors that
kept their states open
and every week, less and less
governors were on the call.
It was kind of interesting
how candid we were, you know,
so we'd get on that call
and somebody would say,
hey guys, I gotta let you know,
this is my last phone
call I'll be on.
My entire team is telling me
that I've gotta
shut down businesses
cause the spread's
getting too bad.
So I'm just here to let
you know that tomorrow,
I'm putting out a press
release and closing the state
and I won't be on
these calls anymore.
And we would say, okay, and
then there was less and less.
So there was times where
it got down to 12 of us
and then a week later
there was eight of us.
And then there was less of us
and down until I was
the only one left.
So it was, it was interesting
times, but I also,
many of those
Republican governors
maybe didn't have the
situation that I had either.
You know, I had an
incredible executive team
that when I made a
decision, they said okay,
that's the decision
and they did it.
And my hospital administrators
were very involved.
We talked many times a day,
when we made decisions,
it was based on science.
It was not based on what
was playing on the news.
That was very helpful.
They were common sense,
reasonable people who wanted
to take care of each other and
the state partnered with them
in ways that I don't think
happened in other states.
Our National Guard and other
entities were heavily involved
in helping them build up
capacity and staffing,
very innovative in
how we approached it,
that I think allowed
us to do what we did.
- What kind of pushback were
you getting behind the scenes,
even if you had
support in the state?
I would imagine, you know,
there had to be some calls
from maybe people at the NIH
or CDC or just whatever,
legal people, whatever,
just saying, hey,
you can stay open,
but we're coming for you
basically one way or another.
- Yeah. I think we got pushed.
I mean, we got push back
from every angle, everywhere.
And even the national
media made it worse
because they just
specifically targeted me.
There would be hotspots
all over the country,
but all they talked about
at night on the news
was South Dakota and
our meat packing plant
or the Sturgis
Motorcycle Bike Rally,
or this irresponsible event,
we were going to be
hosting at Mount Rushmore.
You know, they specifically
went after me in a way
that we'd never seen before.
And we saw the CDC
officials and NIH and Fauci,
specifically attack me
along with Elizabeth Warren
and Rachel Maddow,
night after night.
But we also, you know,
recognized too that people
in my state weren't
necessarily supportive either.
You know, there was times
where it was hard to find
a lot of encouragement, even
from people who lived here.
That my Lieutenant
governor tells the story
that he would get phone calls
from even our best supporters,
that would say, hey, you gotta
get the governor in line.
This is gonna, this is
gonna kill her politically.
And she's gotta
start falling in line
with these other
governors and you know,
to his credit and to
my executive team,
they said she is
firm in her decision.
She has already decided this.
She doesn't have the authority,
therefore she's
not gonna overstep.
And we are in line with her.
And that made it a
wonderful thing for me
because many times those
contentious phone calls
they were taking, they
didn't necessarily
always tell me about,
they knew where I was
and we were a team taking
care of people together.
- Did you ever have a moment
where you almost cracked,
and said okay, I'm gonna
have to do some lockdowns
or some version of something,
like did the pressure
ever get to that point
where you got close?
- You know, I don't
think I ever got close,
although it was hard.
There were days that, that
I would say, you know,
I hung up a phone or got off
a zoom call where I thought,
man, I don't know how
much longer I can do this.
You know, my family
was pretty remarkable.
I have a son that's now 20,
but he was 18 at the time
that sat by my desk for 18
hours a day and just sat there.
So, and I think it
was to remind me that
somebody was gonna love me
no matter what, you know.
And then when I got off a phone
call that was contentious,
cause I spent a lot of time
managing other leaders.
I spent a lot of time, you know,
having conference
calls with mayors,
with city council members,
with county commissioners.
You know, once I
made a decision,
I spent a ton of time
communicating with them
about why I was making
the decision I was making.
But when I would hang
up with a phone call
that obviously was contentious
or stressful in a way,
he would say, mom, let's go
shoot baskets for five minutes.
And so we'd go outside
and shoot baskets
for five or 10
minutes and, you know,
get a little bit of a break
and then I'd go back to work.
Or let's go play
cards, but he was good
at giving me some perspective.
And I think my whole family,
you know, being here with me,
made a world of difference.
I mean, they really supported
me and reminded me that,
here in South Dakota, just
because the national leaders
are making very different
decisions didn't mean that
that was gonna be
South Dakota's path.
What I appreciated the most
was that President Trump
let me do my job, is
if Joe Biden had been
in the White House
during this time,
I know for a fact he
would've come after us
and really been punitive against
the state of South Dakota
and done all he
could to destroy me.
And President Trump let
me do my job as governor.
And for that, I'll
always be grateful.
- Are you shocked
or were you shocked,
that during all of
this, the same people
who were calling
Trump, Hitler every day
and all the horrible things
that they would call him,
that he was basically kicking
the power back to the states.
So taking less
power for himself,
less power to the
federal government.
And they were angry
at him for that.
The guy who they said was
the worst of the worst.
- That's right. Yeah.
That's exactly it.
And what I found was
even at the local level,
many mayors and city
council members,
they wanted me to make
the tough decision
so they didn't have to.
And it was so, that's the exact
opposite of President Trump.
It wasn't that he wasn't
willing to make tough decisions.
He was very clear on what
his recommendations were,
but then he let us do our job.
And that's what I kept
saying to the mayors.
And the city
councilman is listen,
this is not my
authority to do this.
You can make
different decisions,
but I want you to know
that I'm gonna be here
holding you accountable as well.
If you shut down your city and
we have a hundred cases there
and then two weeks from
now, you open it back up,
cause people can't
take it anymore.
And you have 500 cases.
I'm gonna blow you up.
I'm gonna call a press
conference and say,
you locked people in their homes
and only let them out
when it got worse.
So I said, I consistently
was reminding people,
why don't you shut off your TV?
Let's talk over the data
and the facts of this virus.
And then just, I'll
call you in the morning.
I know you're nervous.
I know you're anxious.
I know you're uncertain.
So let's just take a night and
I'll call you in the morning
and let's talk again.
And a lot of what happened
during the pandemic was
that kind of communication that
I think was to our benefit.
- I would be remiss if I
didn't back up for a second
and ask you about your
basketball skills.
Do you have some
skills out there?
- They needed some tuning up.
So they were not
horrible in high school.
I did play basketball, but
yeah, that 6'5" son of mine,
can school me every day
on the basketball court.
- So speaking of
sports, actually,
we got a good transition there.
One of the other things
you've been leading on
is actually keeping
boys and girls
in separate sports
leagues and it's okay.
And it's not based in
bigotry or anything else.
Are you shocked that this
even got to your desk
and that you had to kind
of lead on this thing,
cause everyone's
talking about it now,
but you were really doing this.
It's almost two years
ago at this point.
- You know, I started this
fight probably five years ago.
You know, people
don't remember this,
but when I was in Congress,
the federal government came
down and told South Dakota
that we could no longer have
girls events and boys events
in the sport of rodeo,
which, you know,
a lot of people don't
pay attention to rodeo.
So it never made national news.
But to South Dakota, that
was a really big deal.
It's our state sport.
And they told us that it
was too discriminatory
to have a girls' event
and a boys' event.
And that we had to eliminate
all gender references
in that sport statewide.
And I fought them.
I fought them alone.
Nobody really cared at
that time about this issue
or they thought it was
too politically dangerous
to really wade into,
but ended up winning
that argument at that time.
So this is something I'd
been a part of fighting
for many, many
years when it came
to protecting girls sports.
Now that it's a national issue.
I wanted the strongest
bill in the nation,
in the state of South Dakota.
Because I know that this
is a basic fairness issue.
This is about only girls
playing in girls sports.
So they have an opportunity
to be successful
and to succeed, maybe
win a scholarship,
go on and play professionally,
if that opportunity
presents itself.
And that biological males
should not be playing
in their same events.
But it's interesting to me
to watch the kind of attacks
that have come, just
because you know, this,
it serves a political agenda.
For us in South Dakota.
I know that as soon
as we passed a bill that was
going to be put into statute,
it would be challenged in court.
And I did not wanna
pass a flawed bill
that made us vulnerable
to having it overturned
and setting up incredible
precedent that would leave us
in a situation where I
wouldn't be able to enforce
this rule in our state.
And be in a situation where
we would always have to
have boys playing
in girls sports.
So I'm proud of
the bill we passed.
It was something I authored
and the legislature supported.
And now South
Dakota is the state,
that has the most strongest
and court challenged, you know,
will withstand a
court challenged, the
best in the nation.
- Are there court cases
about that right now?
I mean, just in the
last couple weeks,
one of the things we've
covered here is that
the federal government
wants to come after states
that pass bills like this
and potentially withhold
school lunches from kids
in states that do
things like this.
So you're gonna punish the kids
who have nothing
to do with this.
I mean,
- Yeah
- it's typical of
everything going on
with this government, but.
- Yeah, you're exactly right.
You know, there isn't
court challenges right now.
Although if we had
done flawed bills,
then they would've used that
opportunity to undermine them
and set up precedent.
But yes, what's interesting
is the Biden Administration
has come to South
Dakota and said, listen,
you either let boys
play in girls sports
or we're gonna withhold
school lunches.
Which I think is the craziest
thing I've ever heard.
I mean, not only does this
administration not care about
solving our baby formula issue,
but then they go and
threaten to take away food
from children to create an
unfair situation for women.
So they're going after
women, children, and babies.
And it's hard for me to
believe that anybody supports
the Democrat party anymore
after what Joe Biden is doing.
It's amazing to me that
to have this kind of
a left extremist agenda
that they would go after
women and children and
literally threaten taking away,
taking away food
in their schools.
- You mentioned Tom Daschle
before who was a Democrat.
So did, I mean when
you had a guy like him,
who you obviously had
some disagreements with
when you were
younger, of course.
But he, I don't think
he was like a crazy,
crazy lefty the way
they seem to be now,
Do you have a sense
of how that shifted,
maybe how it shifted
in your state?
And I think everyone
can sort of see it
at a national level
at this point.
- No, I would say that at
the time he was serving,
you know, he would've been
a more moderate Democrat
and South Dakota elects a lot
of Democrats to federal level.
People tend to think
of South Dakota
as a very conservative state.
And that's just not
necessarily true.
When we elect officials to
Washington DC, you know.
Tom was what people
probably would call more of
a blue dog Democrat, you
know, maybe cooperated
with Republicans
a little bit more.
It did catch up with him,
some of his votes,
in his way of life.
But when I ran for Congress,
I ran against a Democrat,
that had a very
high approval rating
in the state of South Dakota.
It was a very tough race,
one of the top five races
in the nation at that time.
And even my last race
running for governor
here in South Dakota, I only
won that race by three points.
And it was to a Democrat who
embraced Bernie
Sanders policies.
So, you know, I think
a lot of people see
the conservative things that
are going on in South Dakota
and think, wow, well,
that's easy to do
in a red state like that.
Well, we're getting more
and more red all the time,
but there's been a lot of
Democrats that have been elected
in South Dakota and they got
elected by being more populist
rather than the extreme
far left that we see
in the country right now.
- Do you see a parallel between
South Dakota and Florida
in that, you know, DeSantis,
who's now crushing it here
and you guys have many of
the same policies, you know,
he only won by 30,000
votes and it turns out
that the guy he beat,
he became a meth addict.
- Yeah, that's true
- Or maybe maybe was a
meth addict at the time,
I don't know.
- Was a meth head, yeah.
- But the point being
that you guys both
won pretty close races
and the country could look
very, very different
if, you know,
South Dakota and
Florida had turned blue.
I mean it radically would.
- Yeah, I think, I think so.
You know, Ron and I got elected
to Congress the same year,
we served for eight years
together in the house
and both ran for governor
at the same time.
We both have very
different states,
but we do have higher than
average elderly populations.
So with that, all got
taken into account
when we were making
our decisions as well,
recognizing we had a higher
ratio of our population
that would be vulnerable.
But at the end of the day,
I think we made the decisions
that were best for our people.
We still made very
different decisions.
You know, he had some
closures at different times,
different mandates, but I do
think that every governor,
it's easy for people
to pass judgment
on them from the outside
two or three years later.
I will say that for every
single governor, it was a,
it was a difficult time,
every decision was hard.
- So you've been ahead
on a couple things.
We talked about COVID obviously,
and some of the gender stuff,
one of the other things
you've been talking about
is food security.
And for my audience,
obviously doesn't watch
much mainstream media,
but they are paying attention
to what's going on online.
I mean, every day
there are new headlines
about, you know,
meat producing fields
and all of these things
that are on fire.
Factories seem to be burning up,
that our food security
really seems to be
threatened right now.
There was this weird
thing in Kansas
with 2000 cattle dying out of
nowhere, supposedly from heat.
What is going on here?
- Well, I've been talking
about food security
as a national security
issue for 15 years.
I served on a
committee in the state.
Of course I am a
farmer and a rancher.
That's how I've made my
living my entire life,
until I got involved in
government and politics.
But beyond that, I
served on a committee
that oversaw the federal
farm programs in the state.
But I recognized that
America has always embraced
a food policy of having it be
diversified in the country.
So that one person doesn't
control our food supply,
that many different farmers
and small businesses do
and processors, but
that also we have had
a cheap food policy.
We wanted every single
family in this country
to be able to afford to put food
on the table for their families.
And I've been drawing attention
for 15 years to the fact
that we are losing both of
those battles that we have.
We have more and more
foreign countries
buying up our
processing systems.
They're buying up our
fertilizer companies,
our chemical companies,
our processing facilities,
not only is China
manipulating their currency,
but stealing our IP,
building up their military.
They're also buying our land.
They own a lot of our
food supply chain system.
And when another country
controls our food,
that is when they control us.
So they're not dummies.
And I think that
these higher costs
are already forcing
families to make decisions
on what they can buy and what
they can feed their families.
And when we get another
country that truly does control
the entire supply system,
that's when America gets scary.
You know, I think a
virus was a situation
where the entire
country was nervous.
I would say, wait
till there's no food
on the grocery store shelves.
And that's really
when you start to see
our way of life
being threatened. So.
- So, so what do we
do? What do we do?
I mean, Biden said it
himself a couple months ago,
food shortages, you know,
I think what was it,
the Economist or one
of the major magazines,
the food shortages are coming.
World economic forum worrying
about it, talking about it.
Bill Gates is now the
largest farm land owner
in the United States.
I mean, what do you do
as a governor of state?
What do you do?
- Well, first of all, I have
to be honest and talk about it.
This administration's
not talking about
solving the problem.
And in fact, they're
facilitating foreign countries
coming in and buying up
our systems and our land.
So the administration
being honest
and recognizing it,
is a real challenge.
In solving it
would be important.
Cutting regulations to allow
more of our American businesses
to buy back these facilities,
to be in production agriculture,
to grow our own
food is important.
Right now they're attacking
our farmers and ranchers.
And they're penalizing them
and putting heavy regulations
on them that don't allow
people to work on their land.
Don't allow their
children to participate
in the business at all.
And in South Dakota here,
we've been aggressive in
cutting back regulations.
We've also been
aggressive in building
our own processing plants.
I've given millions
and millions of grants
to people who want to
build a meat packing plant,
or expand a facility that
would put value added food
on the table for families here,
so that we control
our own destiny.
And that many, many of
these producers can control
their own supply chain to
get it right to the customer.
We're bypassing a lot of these
big corporations that own
the systems, that are
stealing the profits away from
those that are actually
growing the food
and making sure we're
putting that control back
in the hands of the consumer,
who needs to put that
food on the table.
- What do you make of this
administration when it comes
to everything we've
talked about here?
Do you believe that
it's ineptitude
or do you think that
this is intentional?
Everything that's
happening right now?
- Well, you know, there's
been a year and a half here
where I thought, you
know, this guy's like
the George Castanza
of government.
Like his, every instinct
he makes is just wrong.
- Right, he should be
making the reverse.
- If he would wake
up in the morning.
Yes, he should.
It just so, but I believe now,
that much of this
is intentional.
That there's no way
that somebody is making
decisions like this,
that truly loves America.
He is crippling our country
and you can't possibly be
making these kinds of decisions
and have it just be a mistake.
So there's an agenda
here to control people
and it's been in place
for a period of time.
I'm not gonna say it's coming
straight outta Joe Biden.
I think most of the time,
he's not even aware of
what's going on necessarily,
but he's being controlled
by people who definitely
do not want a Republic to
continue in this country.
I would've never thought
three or four years ago
that we'd have the conversations
we're having today.
That a country could change
as fast as America has.
I knew when I
served in Congress,
that I served with members
that were socialists.
That embraced the policies
and their ways of life,
but they never would've
admitted it publicly.
And now look what's happened.
They're openly holding
press conferences
and embracing socialist
and Marxist platforms
and programs for the
United States of America.
So if people who think
that, well you know,
this is just another episode
like we saw in the seventies,
you know, yes, we've been
through challenging times
in the past.
Some of them traits
are, are familiar.
Some of the riots and
the violence, you know,
we can remember in our history
where we've seen that before.
But this is different
because they are trying
to remake America and
they're getting more traction
than they've ever gotten before.
- Speaking of that, did
you guys have any of the,
the crazy riots that
we saw everywhere?
I mean, it was usually in blue
states and in blue cities,
but did you have any of
that during the summer
of tolerance or violence,
depending on which
way you look at it?
- Well, we had one
event that was planned
a protest in our largest
city that was planned
and I pre-staged
my National Guard,
to several different
cities that night
and also my law
enforcement officers.
And then just told those,
I set up emergency
operations centers
in each of these cities too,
and coordinated everything
with the local law enforcement
and mayors in those towns.
But that evening in Sioux Falls,
which is our largest city.
I said, as soon
as we, they throw
the first water
bottle we're going in.
And so we did, this crowd
of thousands of people,
you know, built
throughout the night,
moved throughout the city.
And when it started
to get violent,
we immediately moved
in and shut it down
and said we weren't
going to stand.
Peaceful protests we will allow,
that's our constitutional right.
But as soon as
one thing happens,
that that turns it into
something very different.
South Dakota wouldn't
stand for it.
So it was remarkable what
happened in South Dakota,
because we didn't have
issues after that period,
people knew where we stood.
They knew we protected
law and order.
And even it was kind of amazing
because they had spread out
so far, in the city, you know,
having enough help was
incredibly important.
We saw citizens come
out, they were armed,
to help protect the
downtown streets.
We had motorcycle
groups come out
and say, we've got these blocks.
The National Guard can
move down to an area
where there's more of a threat.
And it was amazing to
watch people partner
with our law enforcement
and with our guard members
to keep everybody safe.
- Are you telling
me that people who,
law abiding own weapons
for their own self defense,
sometimes do good things.
Cause that's not
the meme out there.
- Yeah, no, they did
incredible things
during that period of time.
It was remarkable to see.
Even when President Trump
came to Mount Rushmore,
we had protests throughout
the Black Hills.
Cause at that time
across the country,
people were tearing
down monuments.
They were tearing down statues.
And then here South Dakota
dared to have a celebration
in honor of the leaders
on Mount Rushmore
and president Trump
and our freedom
and you know, organized
protestors, those
seeking violence,
showed up and tried to
destroy the monument.
Tried to create problems that
evening for the president.
And we had hundreds and
hundreds of civilians.
And again, a lot of these
motorcycle groups came in,
rolled into these small towns
and kept law and order for us,
so that we could
have a peaceful event
where we really did get
to focus on America.
- I'm sure you hear it probably
every day of your life.
But I had never been to Mount
Rushmore until, you know,
a year or two ago when I
went, I mean, it is truly,
I've been to every monument
and every, you know,
important place in
the United States.
It is the most breathtaking,
absolutely incredible.
it's mind boggling that
this thing was even made.
It really is.
- It is. And at the
time it was made
the incredible efforts
that had to be done.
And you know, what's
interesting is just the need
to protect it at
this day and age too.
You know, we have,
still, security up there,
making sure it's
protected from protestors
who try to dump red
paint down the faces
or try to set off explosives
to send a message,
that's anti-American so, it
is a special treasure for us.
You know, people always get
South and North Dakota confused
and I'm constantly
saying to them,
North Dakota got all the oil,
South Dakota got Mount Rushmore
and we're okay with that.
- So let's just go through
a couple of the other
hot button issues that
you've been talking about.
Obviously, as we're taping this,
we're holding it
for a couple days.
So it is possible that
this Roe v. Wade decision,
because the Supreme Court is
making all these decisions
this week that are
being released.
It may have been
already announced,
but it sounds like Roe v.
Wade is going to be reversed.
According to this leaked
briefing that we heard about
a couple months ago,
obviously your pro-life,
what do you think the
policy of South Dakota
is going to be going forward?
Will there be any room on
that related to some of these
extreme cases, et
cetera, et cetera.
- Well, right now
in South Dakota,
there are no abortions being
performed in our state.
Which is something
I'm very proud of.
You know, I ran
for governor saying
I wanted to be the most pro-life
governor in the country.
Every action we've taken,
every bill we've passed
has been protecting every
single innocent life.
And you know, this decision
will be monumental
in the country.
South Dakota has a
trigger law in place.
So as soon as that
decision comes forward,
abortions will be illegal in
the state of South Dakota,
except for in protection
of the life of the mother.
I have already
told my legislature
that we may have a need
for a special session
to see what we can
do to really partner
and help care for mothers
that are in a situation
where they have a baby
that may need healthcare,
that found themselves
in a crisis situation
or facilitate better
adoption situations
to connect people better.
Make sure that these
children have the opportunity
to grow up in a home
where they're loved
and cherished and
can be successful for
many years to come.
So with that trigger
law is important,
but there also may be
a need to make sure
that we clarify that the
mothers aren't the ones
that should be punished
in this situation.
That it is those who
perform the abortions
and knowingly break
the law, doing it
that need to be punished.
- Are you getting any traction
on some of those programs,
whether it's adoption or
figuring out other ways
to help the kids.
Cause to me that's
where conservatives,
I think can really make
ground, make some headway
with some of the
disaffected liberals.
There's so many disaffected
liberals right now.
So many people that don't
want eight month abortions,
seven month abortions,
all the crazy stuff
coming outta California.
But they view something
like, oh, no abortions.
And now no government
help as just too far.
- Yeah. And I agree, we don't
spend nearly enough time
talking about taking care
of mothers in crisis.
We just don't.
And we should, because
that's really the challenge
that most of these
young women are in.
And they're scared
of, is you know,
it's one thing to tell me,
I gotta have this baby.
How do I get to a doctor? How
do I feed it when it's here?
How do I care for
it? And then what?
So when I became governor, I
made it one of my major issues
is to facilitate adoption
and foster care services.
We've dramatically increased
the amount of foster families
in our, in our state.
I made it a priority to say
that in every major speech,
I would talk about
foster care and adoption.
And we've seen that, be
facilitated in many, many ways
and grow throughout the state.
And encourage these
foster families
to keep these children
in their homes
and to adopt them.
So we also, as a
state passed a law
that would help pay
for the home studies
that are required of adoptions
and to help with a
financial burden of bringing
a child into their
home permanently.
So I have in my family,
my brother's adopted
three children.
My sisters adopted
a son, you know,
we're very familiar
with adoption.
I grew up with a foster brother.
And so it's something
I'm passionate about.
And I think it's an
opportunity for all of us
to start recognizing that
we're in these positions
to take care of people,
to serve people.
And that a lot of this
pro-life discussion
is about making sure
that those mothers
have an opportunity
to have a quality life
and to make sure their
babies are in a safe home.
- So let's just do one
more hot button issue
before I let you go.
We sort of talked about
guns for just a second,
a moment ago, but you're
obviously a big defender
of the second amendment.
We have all of this
legislation trying to be passed
or half passed right now in
wake of the Uvalde shooting.
I guess, well broadly,
what is your position
on the second amendment?
I guess that's obvious,
but what do you think
is gonna happen as the federal
government seems to want
to encroach more on the
states, related to gun rights?
- Well, the very first bill
that I signed as governor
was constitutional carry.
It had been vetoed by
the previous governor
a couple of times.
And I was passionate about
this constitutional right.
So we had a big
ceremony in the rotunda
and celebrated this bill
finally becoming law
in the state of South Dakota.
And since then we've passed
quite a few different bills
and pieces of legislation
that make it clear
that if you wanna exercise
your second amendment rights
in South Dakota, please do.
In fact, this last
year I removed all fees
for concealed carry permits.
Any permit that
would be required.
And said the state of
South Dakota would even pay
for a person's federal
background check.
So there would be zero cost
to exercising your second
amendment rights here.
I think it's important
we lead by example
and the discussion on
violence and tragedies
that happens in this country
is heartbreaking to see.
I think what we need
to remember though,
is that this is a
constitutionally
protected right.
And it is a right,
that guarantees
all the other Bill of Rights.
It is the militia,
the citizen militia,
that fought for our
freedom in this country
during the Revolutionary War
did so with their own weapons.
With the weapons that they
had to feed their families,
to hunt deer and squirrel.
They used those to
fight for their freedom
and they wanted it enshrined
in our Bill of Rights
that we always have the
opportunity for each individual
in this country to be
able to defend themselves
with their own weapons.
And it wasn't from other
people in their community.
It was from a
corrupt government.
And that is what I
think is imperative
is that we remain
focused on the reason
that the second amendment
exists, talk about the history
and ensure that we keep
that protection in place.
- It is unclear to me whether
the government is inept,
corrupt or malicious
at this point, but,
- I would say all of the above.
- It might, it
might be all three.
And of course, governor,
I cannot let you go
without asking the most
important question.
You knew it was coming,
are you're running in 2024?
Come on. No, evasive answers.
- I thought you were asking
what I had for
breakfast this morning.
So, you know, I
have no plans to.
I'm running for
reelection this year
and I have to ask the
people of South Dakota,
if they'll trust me
to work with them
for the next four years.
I'm hopeful they will.
And I also think 2024,
there'll be a lot of people
running for president
at that point.
I think anybody who wants
to run for president,
that gets up every single day
and that's their
number one desire.
Maybe that's not the kind
of president that we want.
It might be time for this
country to have someone
who steps up because
they feel a duty
to protect this country
and our freedom.
- Amen.
Governor Kristi Noem,
thank you very much.
- Great to visit
with you. Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.